- Dans la plateforme de Valérie
Plante en 2017, les mots "arme"
ou "sécurité" au sens policier
du terme n'apparaissaient pas.
Pourtant, c'est devenu un thème
incontournable cette année.
- Montréal est pas sécuritaire.
Les gens ont peur.
- Ma priorité a toujours été
la sécurité des citoyens et
citoyennes dans les quartiers.
- Les Montréalais sont-ils
plus ou moins en sécurité?
Voici ce que nous disent
les statistiques entre 2018 et
le 30 septembre de cette année,
une courbe en dents de scie
qui pourrait atteindre un sommet
puisqu'il reste encore trois
mois de données à compiler.
♪ ♪ ♪
Concrètement, y a-t-il
plus de coups de feu qui
sont tirés dans nos rues?
Oui, la tendance est clairement
à la hausse pour l'infraction
qu'on appelle "décharger
une arme à feu".
♪ ♪ ♪
Et quand on se compare, Montréal
n'est quand même pas Toronto,
rappelle Valérie Plante.
C'est vrai, si on regarde
le taux d'homicides,
Montréal a une place enviable
au Canada, selon les données
de l'année dernière.
Ça, c'est pour les meurtres.
Mais si on regarde l'ensemble
des crimes commis avec une arme
à feu, il y a eu une baisse,
ces trois dernières années,
du taux pour 100 000
habitants à Toronto.
Rien de notable à Montréal.
Est-ce parce que la force
policière de Montréal est moins
nombreuse qu'ailleurs? Non.
Par rapport à la population
totale, pour 100 policiers
à Montréal, il n'y en a
que 80 environ à Toronto
et Winnipeg, 75 à Calgary.
Reste à voir si cette question
de la sécurité sera déterminante
quand les électeurs seront
devant les urnes